ce sera la plus grande conférence sur
l'environnement depuis le grand sommet
de la terre de rio en 1992
cette conférence on l'appelle et on
entend ça régulièrement dans l'immédiat
la coop 21
qu'est ce qu'une coque c'est au pc op
cannes friends of practice dans le fond
ce sont les lie les pays qui ont signé
le protocole de kyoto en 1997 vous savez
les changements climatiques ça fait
quand même assez longtemps qu'on s'y
intéresse de la fin des années 80 on s'y
est intéressé plus plus intensément on
ne crée le giec le groupe d'experts sur
la science du climat et en 95 on a
commencé à se réunir à tous les ans pour
essayer de régler le problème climatique
et donc deux ans plus tard en 97 à la
coop 3 à kyoto on a signé le fameux
protocole de kyoto qui dans le fond
visait à réduire les émissions des pays
industrialisés
parce que on a reconnu à l'époque ce
sont eux les vrais responsables dans le
fond du phénomène du réchauffement
climatique de l'augmentation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre depuis
la fin du 19e siècle et donc une
cinquantaine de pays qui ont signé ce
protocole ça représente à peu près la
moitié des émissions totales du monde
les américaines ont signé les
canadiennes hosni et cetera mais
finalement on s'est rendu compte
rapidement que l'économie mondiale
change et que finalement le protocole
n'était pas suffisant pour contenir le
phénomène non d'ailleurs ça avait pris
du temps pour qu'on le mette en marche
et oui ça a pris huit ans avant que le
protocole entre en vigueur que tous les
pays le ratifient tu en 2050 c'est entre
en vigueur à montréal
la conférence de montréal et à cette
époque il restait que 36 ou 37 pays qui
avaient signé le protocole les
américains l'avaient signée mais ne
l'avait pas ratifié et finalement on se
retrouve à qu'une entente qui
représentent à peu près le quart des
émissions mondiales et donc pas
suffisant et c'est un accord qui était
assez limité dans le temps aussi c'est
un accord qui qui qui visait une période
précise entre 2008 et 2012
et donc voilà ça c'est terminé et c'est
pour ça que puisque ça se terminer en
dès 2007 on s'est dit il faudra donner
une suite à ça et donc on s'était donné
rendez vous à copenhague en 2009 pour
signer qui ôte aux deux et ça a été un
échec
monumental on vit toujours un peu sur
les effets de cet échec parce que
pendant plusieurs années après 2009 ici
presque rien passé sur le front
climatique et c'est pour ça qu'en 2012
on a dit il faut donner une suite à
kyoto absolument et donc en 2015 au plus
tard
on va signer un accord pour donner suite
à toutes 2015 c'est maintenant petit à
paris et c'est à paris de là
l'importance de la conférence de là
l'importance de s'y intéresser à cette
conférence sur le climat de paris
etienne louis exactement parce que voilà
c'est la conférence où on veut se donner
une suite à kyoto qui finalement
puisqu'il n'y avait rien après 2012 on
l'avait prolongé cet accord de kyoto
jusqu'en 2020 on veut éviter qu'il ya
encore un trou après 2020 et donc c'est
pour ça dans le fond que cet événement
semble si gros si importants qu'on en
parle partout dans les médias parce
qu'on veut signer enfin un accord et on
veut éviter surtout d'un échec comme on
ait eu à copenhague parce qu'après ça
c'est des années et des années à s'en
remettre
éviter ça et que contrairement kyoto
soit dans le coule pas seulement le
quart des émissions exactement
exactement c'est le groupe c'est le gros
changement puis c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire le plus possible maintenant plus
précisément donner une suite à kyoto
auquel sont les objectifs plus précis de
la conférence de paris
mais d'abord on le sait la science nous
dit il faut contenir le réchauffement
climatique à 2 degrés celsius donc avoir
un accord avec 10 des cibles qui vont
faire en sorte que nous pourrons faire
ça pour l'instant on n'a pas ça les
cibles qui sont sur la table ne sont pas
suffisantes pour ça et surtout vous le
disiez conclure un avoir un accord
universel donc ne pas suivre le modèle
de clio tous y avait que quelques pays
dans le fond qui étaient contraints
maintenant on veut les plus grands
pollueurs de la planète l'économie
mondiale a changé
lalala l'inde la chine l'indonésie le
brésil sont devenus de grands pollueurs
et donc on veut vraiment les amener la
table et l'autre chose dont on va
beaucoup entendre parler c'est l'argent
on s'est entendu pour aider les pays en
développement à s'adapter au changement
climatique qui va payer
combien alors tout ça ça fait toujours
l'objet de très très fortes négociations
en terminant en quelques mots les
principaux obstacles pour parvenir à ça
mais je le disais ce fameux fossé
nord-sud vous allez le voir on va
l'entendre pendant deux semaines les
pays en développement qui vont dire vous
êtes responsable nous subissons les
conséquences
aidez-nous davantage à faire face à ça
et surtout prenez des engagements plus
fermes avec des cibles plus ambitieuses
pour que ça soit vous dans le fond qui
règle les problèmes